So let's look at an example of how we use try. So here we've created a try block
and everything inside this block will execute and it'll execute normally until
there's an exception raised. If there's an exception raised, it will jump to
look for an exception handler. And in this case we have an exception handler for
the IO error exception. So if that's raised, it'll be handled here. And then
after the tri block finishes we'll continue with the print. Note there's a few
things in this code you might now have seen yet. You should be starting to get
comfortable with that. If you are confused by things like, for example this line
here. You can probably figure out on your what it does. Either looking through
the documentation or trying it in the interpreter. So, let's try running this
code, and I'm trying it in a directory that does not have Any trippy file and we
can see what happens when this line executed, the exception was thrown it was an
I O error exception that got bound to the variable E and then when we print out
there, we can see error reading file, the message that came with the exception
and then after that it doesn't return here, execution continues following the
try block. The print statement. One of the things exceptions do, is make it much
harder to follow the flow of execution of a program. Code can jump all around.
It's different from procedures, which do make code jump around. But when we call
a procedure normally and it returns normally, we know it's always going to come
back to the same point. With exceptions, anywhere in here can jump to another
place. So now, I've created a file called trippy, but I've made it unreadable.
Don't worry if you don't understand these commands, these are just ways to
create and file make it unreadable. And now, I am going to try again and we see,
we still got the IO error exception but the message is different, Now we got a
permission failure. Because we don't have permission to read the file that
exists there. Let's make the file readable and try again. Now, we get something
different. So now the open succeeded. We got to the next line. The next line
does a read line. That succeeded. We read in the line, what a trip. And then we
got to the next line which tries to convert that line, to a number, using the
int constructer. That's through a Value Error exception. And so when an
exception is raised inside a triblock, it jumps to the exception handlers. The
IOError exception handler doesn't match the Value Error. So it doesn't handle
it. There's no exception handler that does handle value error. So, that
exception gets raised to the next level. In this case, causing the program to
crash, and that's why instead of ever getting to continuing, we got this error
when we ran the program.